concern is growing in Hong Kong that the
number of coronavirus cases here could
be about to sharply increase a shortage
of face masks has resulted in long lines
forming outside some shops as people try
to protect themselves as much as
possible morning so I've been waiting
for six to seven hours mass to try to
control the spread of the virus the Hong
Kong government has suspended most rail
and ferry services to and from the
mainland but some border crossings are
still open and flights are operating
which has led to criticism from many in
Hong Kong who want all routes between
here and China closed adding to the
concern it's estimated as many as
300,000 Hong Kong residents visited the
mainland during the Lunar New Year
holiday with many still to return
government medical experts say the city
needs to be on alert for more infections
most of the confirmed cases in Hong Kong
are being treated at this hospital where
this week several nurses went on strike
for a day as part of a wider union
protest against the government's
response to the outbreak of the virus
the threatening more strike action next
week which could coincide with an
increase in the number of cases in Hong
Kong in Tokyo a second flight landed
carrying Japanese citizens evacuated
from Wuhan as it did the government
confirmed some passengers on wednesday's
first flight tested positive for the
virus looking the National Institute of
infectious diseases have reported to us
three new cases of corona virus related
diseases the city they left behind
Wuhan remains largely under lockdown
most people are choosing to stay indoors
but among the few signs of commerce
delivery businesses are being kept busy
taking medical supplies to hospitals my
extravagant hope is to get some sleep as
delivery men we cannot be caught great
but there are many people out there who
need medical supplies but there is a
shortage of some equipment including
kits needed to test patients because of
that many experts outside China believe
the actual number of cases may be a lot
higher than what the government is
reporting Wayne hey al-jazeera
Hong Kong